this tarantula has a truly excellent
nickname meat bamboochula it's the only
known tarantula to live in bamboo grass
bamboochilla was first discovered in
northern thailand by this wildlife
youtuber a spider jumped out when he was
cutting a bamboo branch in a forest near
his home
can you imagine you're at home minding
your own business and suddenly a
youtuber cuts off your roof and you're
known to science
these tarantulas usually get their homes
by waiting for other animals like
insects or rodents to drill holes in
bamboo tubes
using bamboo as a home means that the
spiders don't have to dig or build nests
on their own but bamboo isn't the only
thing that makes these spiders special
they've also got unique reproductive
organs and so the spider turned out to
be an entirely new genus
which is kind of a big deal because it's
the first time in 104 years that
anyone's found a new tarantula genus in
asia
a team of thai researchers recently
reported all of this in a scientific
journal called zookeys
bamboochilla's official name is taxinus
bambus taxinus after tax in the great a
king who ruled thailand in the 1700s and
bambus is another nod to bamboo
follow from our creepy crawly science